Cet été, j'ai eu la chance de réaliser un rêve de gosse. Je suis parti à
NEW YORK ( Alicia Keys )
A cause des films américain, j'ai l'impression que le nom des villes américaines nous paraissent toujours extrêmement stylé
Boston, Seattle, Chicago, Pittsburgh
J'aimerais tellement un jour dire a quelqu'un, juste pour le style :
"euh.. demain.. demain je peux pas, j'ai un truc à faire à Washington"
Moi j'adore le nom des villes en France mais peut être que la chanson " New York" d'Alicia Keys et Jay-Z, elle aurait un peu moins marché avec par exemple....
Amiens...
Avec sa gare, sa poste et son Auchan....
Tu vas te mettre-e bien.
Alors grâce à ces jours, je parle de moins en moins mal anglais, hein ça c'est cool
par contre mon accent anglais est horriblissime, les américains ne me comprennent pas
Histoire vraie, j'ai demandé un jour à un monsieur
Merci
Il a comprit
qui ressemble beaucoup à
quand t'as un accent... de merde.
D'ailleurs j'ai passé mon séjour à me croire cool en balançant à tout le monde :
"ciao, rest in peace"
" bye bye, rest in peace"
Et c'est seulement à la fin du séjour que j'ai réalisé que ça voulait dire " repose en paix" hein.. donc je suis passé pour un mec plutôt morbide.
"bye et repose en paix"
Bon au début j'ai eu un peu de mal a m'adapter,
Par exemple quand j'ai vu la taille des parts de pizza là-bas
J'ai envie de leur dire: Est-ce que je peux avoir une part de part de pizza s'il vous plaît?
A New York quand il fait très chaud en été dans les lieux public ils mettent la clim glaciale
Du coup ton corps ne cesse de faire: "chaleur extrême, Froid glaciale, Chaleur extrême"
Et moi mon corps il n'était pas prêt à ça... Alors il a réagit, il s'est exprimé, et d'une manière plutôt élégante
Dans ma tête la clim elle n'était pas réglée sur froid, elle était réglée sur le mode
Je suis allé dans une salle de sport, la clim était tellement forte, je vous jure c'est vrai
J'ai couru avec mon manteau
Depuis la douche de ma chambre d'hôtel, j'avais une super vue sur New York c'était vraiment magnifique
Par contre au début il y a un petit détail que j'ai trouvé un petit peu chelou
Alors je me suis dit, peux être qu'à New York tout le monde fait comme ça
Les gens ils prennent leur douche sans rideau ils s'en foutent tu vois
Alors j'ai fait avec
New York me voilà !
Et puis je me suis renseigné
Et j'ai découvert que les mecs de l'hôtel
Ont juste oublié de mettre un rideau à ma douche
Génial, j'ai donc montré ma b*te à tout New-York
Times Square c'est un quartier incroyable
Où tu trouves plein de gens excentriques
Qui viennent partager leur passion leur délires
Leur convictions et il y a même des mecs qui font de la pub
à l'américaine mais pour leur religion
Alors je respect ça mais c'est quand même un concept qui m'a un peu étonné
là-bas à New-York c'est la culture du "tips"
du pourboire, c'est presque obligatoire
de donner 15%, 20% de la somme
en plus quand tu payes. Et les taxis pour augmenter leur pourboire, ils veulent paraître sympas en s'intéressant un peu à toi.
Mais en même temps tu sens qu'ils sont un peu soûlé de le faire à chaque clients, du coup ça donne un mix bizarre
de mec sympa mais soûlé.
Les new-yorkais sont plutôt cool, en tout cas ceux que j'ai croisé était franchement accueillant et marrant.
Par exemple une fois dans un resto' j'ai demandé au serveur le nom du Wi-Fi
il m'a répondu:
Imagine tu fais cette blague dans un resto' où les pizzas sont dégueux
Comment t'as trouvé ta pizza?
Euh...dégueulasse
Bah voilà t'as le mot de passe; pizzas dégueulasses
Euh...pourquoi on parle français tout d'un coup là?
Très très bonne question. Je vais euh...je vais en parler à mon...à ma b*te.
J'ai même croisé certains d'entre vous là-bas à New-York
Je garde pleins de souvenirs cool dans la tête, j'ai vraiment adoré ce voyage. J’espère que vous aussi vous aurez la chance d'aller un jour à New-York.
Je voulais finir en vous laissant sur le morceau "NEW YORK" de Jay-Z et Alicia Keys,
mais j'ai pas les droits musicaux dessus.
Alors je vais vous faire ma petite version à moi.
Bon je tente un snap complétement dangereux. Eeeh ça va ou pas?
Rest in peace.